you
[Music]
earning everyone thank you for coming I
hope you enjoyed the earlier part of the
morning this is the session on machine
reading and comprehension and the way
that we are going to format this session
is we'll have four talks each of which
will be about 12 minutes or I might at 1
followed by a very brief moment of
questions and then we'll have a longer
panel discussion which we are going to
try to position as a hallway
conversation that you are participants
in and observers of so later on when
we're having our hallway conversation up
here if you want to join in and ask a
question or make an observation from
your own experience please then we'll
have mics available for you to join so
that's the format but you know half
talks and then half panel discussion
again the topic is machine reading and
comprehension our first speaker is percy
liang who in one way needs very little
introduction but just for the sake of
giving the introduction percy is an
assistant professor of computer science
at Stanford University his research
interests include modeling natural
language semantics and developing
machine learning methods to infer rich
latent structures using very limited
supervision among his many awards I'll
just point out that Percy was the
recipient of the Microsoft research
faculty fellowship in 2014 and I think
he's done gone on to do fabulous things
with that so thank you very much Percy
my clicker
all right thanks I'll Lucy for inviting
me and thanks everyone for being here
I'm really happy to be able to share
some of my thoughts on question and
answering so when I was in grad school I
spent a lot of time thinking about how
to design kind of more clever models and
algorithms and I think as time went on I
kind of began to realize to kind of the
importance of you know data sets and as
you can see in a lot of different of
well of AI datasets are kind of a
primary driver of a lot of the progress
from switchboard and speech recognition
and imagenet and object recognition all
the parallel text you have on a web for
machine translation and human games and
self play in alphago so what about kind
of question answering what is the state
of affairs this is something that's kind
of near and dear to my heart so over the
last five years I've kind of spent a lot
of time thinking about what data sets
should look like and I kind of want to
share some of the lessons that we
learned and in the back of my mind was
this kind of idea that we wanted
datasets that couldn't be solved by
quote cheap Trick's so you really had to
solve the problem to do well on these
datasets so from this perspective I
think the idea of semantic parsing was
very kind of attractive where you have
to take sentences and kind of convert
them break them down into pieces
combining them into these logical forms
and kind of execute them to get the
answer so in that paradigm we started
kind of building the first days in 2013
with young and Brandt and others on web
questions what I really liked about this
data is that we actually took a real
kind of user queries from a search
engine so the questions were kind of on
a realistic you know came from a
realistic distribution but on the other
hand be this realism also caught up with
us because we found quickly that most of
the questions couldn't actually be
answered by the structured knowledgebase
even though it was you know quite large
that resulted we start we wanted to get
you know oops sorry about that time to
take a break we started with a hundred
thousand questions but we whittled down
to only six because of how much mismatch
between questions and the knowledge
space there was so ended up we're
getting becoming kind of a noisy data
set and there wasn't that much kind of
compositionality so two years later we
created another data set called we could
table questions and here the idea was to
get a much cleaner and compositional
data set
so you had a questions like and what
city did pewters last first-place finish
occur and he had this table which you
were meant to look at and try to reason
about to answer the question so in this
particular example you might look at the
position column select the first rows
Simic select the last one select the row
and then report the venue so this is
kind of something that requires a bit
more reasoning on this kind of
structured object so the nice thing I
did was compositional it was clean it
was kind of we gave up kind of on the
the realism and made sure that it was
clean and I think there's still quite a
bit of mileage left on the ceiling is
kind of around 90% but the save art is
only kind of 45 percent but maybe maybe
the data set is actually a little bit
too smaller and maybe if it's too hard
it's too small given its complexity and
we've also found that was a little bit
kind of nation be having these tables so
then we moved on to developing our new
dataset is called squad for reading
comprehension and the task is very
straightforward take a passage out a
paragraph about Wikipedia and answer
natural language questions on it like
what causes precipitation to fall
gravity and and so on and here we kind
of gave up on realism and also on you
know really trying hard to make it a
difficult task and just say okay let's
just get a large and clean data set and
see where that goes so we gather 100 K
examples which at a time I guess at the
time was only a year ago but it was you
know much larger than many of the other
data sets of kind of for question
answering reading comprehension and we
ended up with questions which were you
know interesting but you know they
weren't you know super complicated um so
I think about it kind of retrospective
it's kind of a necessary but not
sufficient days on any system that
claims to do reading comprehension just
nail this but it's not enough of just to
nail this we
also did something which I think was
quite useful is that we build us a
platform separately called coda lab to
allow people to submit code and run
reproducible experiments we use this
platform to say that in order to
participate and report test results on
the squad dataset you had to submit your
code and this actually led to you know a
leaderboard with a full of models which
were you know publicly available so more
on that in a little bit so what's the
status so in over in a little bit over a
year there's been 30 different teams on
submitting to this the leaderboard the
best of thumb is now I guess this is MSR
a eighty four point seven percent f1 and
humans ceiling is around 91 okay so when
we submitted this this we had like some
logistic regression based line which got
50 and we're wondering like how long
would it take to four to basically kind
of nail they said this is definitely
faster than I expected I knew that it
was not meant to be especially difficult
data set but I guess once you have a
data set and the community goes at it
progress is made pretty quickly and I
think there are also a lot of
interesting ideas that came out of it
and particularly all these kind of new
sophisticated attention mechanisms which
i think is a one of the you know but I
mean the kind of principal value of
having a dataset is that drives kind of
new types of models I'll just mention a
bunch of other datasets there's ones
which are based on kind of fill in the
blank which has an advantage of being
able to get a lot more data past 100k
there's a question answering which
actually does require reasoning but
they're kind of small there's four
datasets on two of which actually just
came out I think last month or so and
use a trivia QA and quasar so these are
kind of more in the spirit of you know a
squad kind of reading comprehension
mammoth amar Kaul you'll hear a lot more
about later so I'm not going to say much
about it so now I guess the question is
are these you know datasets are enough
to make kind of meaningful progress on
no reading convention so we decided to
look a little bit deeper and we took a
what here's an example passage from
squad and here's a question what is the
name of the quarterback who is 38 in
Super Bowl 33 and if you look at the
question it's it's multi sentence
reasoning you have to do a little bit of
kind of yeah a little bit of reasoning
to answer this and by def which is this
model from u-dub actually gets this
right so you could conclude wow this is
you know that's pretty good then we
decided to have some fun and we inserted
this sentence at the end so Justine is
the name of the quarterback who is
37-inch ample thirty-four okay and what
is my Daffy output Jeff Dean okay so you
know and no human would kind of unless
they're not brewery paying attention
would make this error so you know we did
this more systematically so we took all
the test questions we mutated them by
you know switching named entities and
replacing words with their antonyms we
generated the fake answer we convert it
into a declarative statement and then
you know this process is a little bit
noisy so we had crowd workers fix up the
question so in the end the adversary
would add a sentence to the end of the
passage in hopes of having hi word
overlap with a question but really not
answering the question at all and so
here's the results so this is a one-of
advantage of having everyone's a code
submitted in on collab is that you can
just run all the models so we ran all
these models on this new kind of
adversarial evaluation and the numbers
they'll start left looking less good so
you know basically going from 80s and
mid 70s to more like 50s and 40s so note
that humans on the other hand do not get
fooled very much at all one other thing
that's kind of interesting is that you
notice that some of the order ranking
has also you know reversed so a reason
that was number one and now it's no
longer number one is actually step
points behind mnemonic mnemonic on that
which is doing a you know 56 isn't great
but it's it's better than you know 50 so
I think there's much more to be said on
this but an interest of time I'll move
on so you could ask okay well you
generate these adversarial examples and
really this is not fair because you
should have trained I mean this is the
training set and a test set of different
distributions so when you just train on
these so we did train on these and it
does fix the problem so accuracy only
drops from on one of the models 74 to 70
but now new adversary comes in and
instead of appending the sentence it
prepense them and now again you're down
to 36 and I mean this is kind of a you
know this is kind of where you gets to
kind of an arms race there's a you know
no matter what kind of adversary you you
guard against there's always going to be
something else
that could you know bring your accuracy
down so the way to think about this is
really about evaluation yes you could go
and add these examples to your training
set and guard against them but really
they should be holdout to kind of really
test whether a model has understood it's
the same reason that you don't train on
your test set to get better test numbers
um so so more generally we've been
thinking about you know how do we move
past this kind of just pure data set of
paradigm where you gather train and test
and you measure average accuracy to
really kind of get a more rigorous
notion of whether models are actually
understanding so here's one possible
generalization which is idea of testing
property so what we saw with that model
should be invariant under adding
distracting sentences so you take a test
example you add them distracting
sentences these are new examples which
the model should get right but there's
other one so you the model should also
be in very under paraphrase if you
pervades and sometimes it should also
get a not get fooled if you replace no
entities like the answer john elway with
and you know barack obama or who
ever you should actually return that
entity as well and we found in our
experience actually these kind of
obvious properties do not hold
especially of these kind of very you
know complex neural models which are
kind of fitting all sorts of you know
statistical correlations they actually
don't kind of behave kind of predictably
as you might hope and these the idea of
these property testing ideas is that
they would kind of expose these these
weaknesses and we currently we're kind
of investigating kind of wider space of
adversaries because we're not going to
you know say okay a patent sentence
freep and and you know and you be able
enumerate so we're kind of using
crowdsourcing to try to do that one
thing to kind of idea they think it's
interesting is that you know once you
you know the idea of an adversary is a
the same as the teachers only the
adversaries of at test time and the
teachers kind of a training time okay so
with that I'll wrap up so one of the
things that hopefully we'll discuss a
little bit more is this trade-off
between having a clean data set in a
kind of a realistic data set when you
have a realistic is there's all sorts of
noise that make it kind of really hard
to measure kind of sometimes meaningful
progress and in terms of you know what
data set should we be you know looking
at now I think of data sets is really
kind of you know a progression you know
and every for every time and place there
is should be a data set that kind of
gets at the cusp of you know what is you
know currently solvable and I think
managing data sets difficulty not too
hard not too easy I think is an
important thing if it's going to
actually meaningful we push forward
progress and then I think this idea of
stronger testing of models based on
adversaries and properties I think could
be a really interesting thing to to
explore which will move us away from
this kind of vanilla
train and test our learning paradigms in
mishima okay so with that think the
collaborators and funding agencies take
questions
[Applause]
someone's going to come to you as a mic
not sure if this one is taking questions
yes you can question so I very much
sympathize with this notion of having
invariants that you know your learner
should be respect real bastard respect
to maybe even even called sourcing them
and so on but if we have such a set of
invariants why not actually encode it
not in the test they're not even the
train data but in the model itself as a
priori knowledge I know that this model
will have these invariants no matter
what the gradient descent does and then
the job is done yeah I mean that's a
good question but I think you should
think about invariance is the same rules
as examples in the sense that there
should be things that are training and
things are every test
it's if you have desired invariance you
should encode them but there's always
going to be kind other types of in
variances which you hopefully should be
kind of implied maybe it should be May
were able to generalize across different
types and variances and that's the
argument for train ties displayed okay
thank you very much percy and hold your
questions write them down because there
will be opportunity during our panel
discussion to continue asking in our
speakers the questions so now you get my
the next speaker will be jump on Gao JAL
Fung is the research manager in
Microsoft ai and research group he's
worked on deep learning from text and
image processing and he leads the
development of the AI systems for the
machine reading comprehension question
generation question answering dialog and
business applications I've known Jeff um
for a long time because he was a
principal researcher in the natural
language processing group where he
worked on many things among which web
search
query understanding and especially
statistical machine translation
previously he was at MSR a or not I'm
sorry which I am SRA and worked on in
Chinese input method editors and was
part of the group that developed the
first first Chinese speech recognition
system so Jensen has a long history and
my pleasure to present ok as opposed to
say that I have a long history as I'm
getting older and more interesting
history today I'm going to talk about
and the current standards and at the
same time I'm going to review the
history here the outline of my talk and
Rangoon's
are going to talk about the first two
bullets and the wrangling and talk about
the image model first of all we're going
to review some history a symbolic
approach to question answering in that
case I can use MSR Minet as a case study
and then way back to the and to the
current stage and we talk about new
approaches to mushroom reading
comprehension and the question answering
I think back to early 80's people start
to develop systems called product
systems and they believed at that time
this is a system which can mimic human
brain there are two pillars of their
open search system foot is to simulate
how human brain works so that they can
understand how the mind is formed and
how the mind works although you cannot
open the human brain but you can open
the simulated system but later on people
figured out or even without computer
understanding how human brain works we
can still make the system very very
useful to solve realistic tasks now the
system consists of three components
first is the production rules which are
essentially conditioning action cares if
it like a if then the
and at the time people believe that see
what knowledge can be represented the
using a graph which consists of millions
and billions of production rules I will
still doing this today and that's the
first piece it's like a brain you have a
long-term memory you'd remember all the
knowledge about the world second piece
is working memory this is task specific
let's say if you are given a crashing
you want form an answer then you trivial
work memory working memory by leveraging
useful and relevant informations until
you can generate the answer in your
memory so that's the short-term memory
part and which is also represented as
the state vector hideth the vector in
the modern reckoning the neural network
and the third part is the controller
this is the continued as a reasoning
engine okay how it works back to 1993 I
think before I I was there at the school
I joined Microsoft seeing to ear 2000 so
this is right from my manager Bill Doran
at the time we tried or they actually
tried to pass large amounts of test data
from dictionaries and the data from webs
by identifying entities and that
relationships among entities to create a
joint knowledge graph like this we
believe this can represent or
knowledgeable or what Norwich and with
that graph we call this MANET okay with
that work we can do a lot of things one
of them is question-answering so your
are some question I can find the answer
in the web how it works it works just
like the production system I show that
early given like input query I say who
accessing Abraham Lincoln with us to use
the past
to turn this query interesting all the
logic for which is a graphical
representation of the inquiry
remember the magnet itself is like a big
graph right this is a big graph so we
just sue the question graph into the big
graph to see if I can fix okay if we
stick there then the corresponding test
could be used as a source to generate
the answer then we generate ask this
works beautifully amazingly a lot of
times you can generate the answer using
the sentences that are not in the
original corpus I think bill and team
Lucy and other people they demonstrated
to Bill Gates right 20 years ago and the
vehicle super excited okay
make the real do the product out of it
because it works so beautifully and lay
down apart just not very office then we
do a test we did a test against in kata
do you remember in Qatar if you remember
color you know that me in Cara then we
found that most of the time the approach
field to produce any answer at all even
when an exam sir who's in the coppers
and the linguistic analysis for a put
the puzzle
worked perfectly and what went wrong
when major issue is perforating or what
we call semantic breathing remember they
are the key difference between similar
words and the similar concept for
example there are different ways tons of
different ways of seeing how long a
river is different ways they're more and
more how it's almost impossible for any
somatic approach to capture all these
variations and map them to the same
concept or plantation so in a sense we
hit a wall
in terms of performance by approaching
it that way now back to today 20 years
later a after I joined maggot rocks
immediate rate I think we are still far
from understanding but we've made great
progress for them who have big data we
have get hardware's and most of all we
have better algorithm especially the
neural networks deep learning
reinforcement learning but look back
make sure we still still stick to the
same principle you should know a word PI
the company it keeps now these slides
choose the key difference between a
symbolic approach and the so called
neuro approach on the left hand it's a
symbolic space where the knowledge is
represented using words rotations
templates using high dimensional
discrete space vectors space vectors and
the nice thing about this symbolic space
is
everything is comprehensible there are
people can read it now how the knowledge
hardened already encoded but the problem
is it's not scalable it's not robust to
any perforating migrations therefore
these valuations
so our say on this space is a human
friendly but not computational friendly
on the other side it's a neuro space
where we represent to the wooden ology
using vectors and matrices they are just
numbers which are now human
comprehensible at all the nothing about
that is everything that continues and
the one knowledge can be represented in
a very compact way so it's very
computationally efficient one way to
combine this two space is the mission of
the neural mushroom our neural machine
reading comprehension models what we do
is here we start around the sinorix pace
let's say you have a query you got a
query
written as a test tree my war string
assuming that you already encode the war
Norwich in the neuro space as matrix
portable of vectors then you first of
all Mack the query from symbolic space
to to neuro space using sakoda embedding
model then you do the click ok then do
you do the implants in the semiotics in
the neuro space to generate down sir now
the answer cannot be human
comprehensible until you met the back
into symbolic space using January models
or decoders these are pretty much the
standard included decode the framework
with influence ok the nice thing about
this is that now all these models are
based on continuous functions so if
there is a training day that here you
what the correct answer a is respect to
the input query Q you can compute the
arrow made by the system and through
back propagation updating all the models
using an ending an antenna fashion
that's how the current model works now
give a quick I mean ok I'll click update
a quick overview of the internet and
Percy also mention a model previously in
the previous talk this model try to
mimic the human mind in a way that it
also contains the shared memory which is
like the production rules in the
production system to encode at half the
specific knowledge it also has this walk
walking memory which represented the
using hidden state as containing a
description of the counter state of the
world of the world in a reading process
and it has a controller which is a
reasoning
component and the nice thing about this
yeah it also has the external memory the
M the external can store all the
production rules right and let me give
you a quick update they the system can
listen in concept you can use of to park
when is the memory the the working
memory and the long-term memory the
other part is the reading engine I
talked of all the reason engine using
this example first okay it's a tried to
mimic the influence process of a human
reader from poor when you read a
document have the crashing mind and the
read the document you often read a
document multiple times every time
focusing on different portions of the
document until a fittest financier is
formed in your brain the really nesting
prey and follow the same process give
example given query reason that first
reader the query and they try to
identify useful information for the
memory the memory encoded the inca
passage by from the memory and the try
to use the relevant information generate
the answer then ask itself with the
answer is good enough or not
if the answer is now it's not good
enough then it will update the walking
memory then based on that you will look
for additional useful information in the
shared memory again now this time it
will focus on different portions of the
memory so that you will for update the
state in a way that is more likely a
satisfied answer can be generate it do
it it does it iteratively and finally it
will get out and really answer the the
one property of this approach is a the
number of steps and the model takes
depends on the complexity of the task
it's intuitively correct right when you
read their document to answer crashing
political pencil and how difficult the
document is and how challenging the
question is if it's a very time you need
to read outcome from many times if it's
questioning is simple you read the words
and the guide answer and mimic that
process and the other party is the
memory the long-term memory is supposed
to encode the more knowledge but we are
not doing it by directly encoding the
knowledge graph into the memory directly
instead we are doing so by performing
question answering tasks for example we
found this member upon this knowledge
well we can identify a lot of
question-answer pairs then these
questions appears are used as a training
data for the resonant basically you give
reason that equation then reason they
try to form an answer elaborating useful
and relevant information in the memory
but if you find that in the information
such information is missing in the
memory then the reason that needs to
learn how to seek and the store new
information by updating the memory via
so-called reinforcement and learning so
that it will be able to answer the
question correctly nap time so a hot
this hard works if you take a look at
what eventually encoded in the memory
then you see that there's similar
concepts and relations are paired
together in that and neuro space okay
that's all my pot thank you
[Applause]
okay so I'll go ahead and introduce run
on right now and so around 11:45 target
so my pleasure to introduce Raman to you
he's the group program manager for
search and artificial intelligence in
the bing division his team uses AI
techniques such as machine learning to
solve customer and business problems
across various products including
finding what you're looking for through
Bing and answering open domain questions
through Cortana and he manages the
search platform that runs all of the
complex algorithms including the large
deep learning models to keep being
running thanks great thank you
can you guys hear me think so all right
great
so John Frank and I have been working on
this machine and reading comprehension
space for the last couple years and one
of the things we were talking about we
were thinking about the strategy of
solving this problem was wouldn't be
great if Microsoft could donate a data
set that can help the research community
to solve the problems that we thought
were important so that's what led to ms
marco first just going over a little bit
of evolution of how we've seen these MRC
data sets the first couple were actually
created by Microsoft and I think person
had a longer list so this is sort of a
summary but the problem with the first
few is that they were just too small for
these data intensive algorithms like
deep learning so two of our favorites
here or MC tax and wiki QA so MC test
was a collection of children's stories
sort of like this where some would you
know be story about James the turtle he
was getting in trouble and doing a bunch
of things and that and then you would
ask the question you know what is the
name of the troublemaking turtle and
then you have a multiple choice set of
things like you know fries putting James
Jane and the goal was could I answer
these questions so that's what MC test
was and you know it was really hard to
use deep learning and technologies that
you know tend to work very well on some
of these other data sets like image
recognition so on I saw one one startup
called maluma actually was able to do
that and actually it still has the
best score on this data set after that
there was a set of data sets that were a
lot bigger so what they decided was well
there's a lot of really well-written
content out there either in like news
stories or things like that and what we
could do is just turn them into
fill-in-the-blank questions so this is
an example of passage they removed the
entities to try and anonymize it and
then your question sometimes in this
example for CNN was the question would
come from the summary of that article
and they would remove the entity there
and your goal was to guess which entity
from that passage could fill that in so
the idea is if you actually are able to
do reading comprehension you should be
able to fill in that summary but then
there was some analysis that show that
you can actually do pretty well on this
without actually doing reading
comprehension so or there's a bunch of
tricks you can do to do this so I think
this goes back to what percy was saying
is we need to create data sets that are
untrackable I forgot the exact phrasing
used but yeah we want to do things that
really move us towards algorithms that
really comprehend the next set of data
sets are these span answer data sets so
Squad is the most popular with this
other one called News QA and it looks
like this so similar to ask the question
where did Tessa live for much of his
life and there was this passage came
from Wikipedia and your goal was to pick
this path or pick the span that says New
York hotels and the way this is
generated is they would take a random
sample of these Wikipedia pages and then
they would ask crowdsource judges to
actually ask the questions and then ms
marco was our contribution and there's a
couple of ways that this is different a
fully summarized in the next slide but
the biggest differences here are we
don't just want people to pick a span we
want people to actually human synthesize
an answer or human generate the answer
and this is an example of one of the
queries that you can find in ms marco so
the question is will I qualify for OSAP
if I'm you and Canada and what we do is
and these are by the way real queries
that come to our search engines we've
anonymized them and we give you a bunch
of documents which could answer the
question
and some snippets that we thought were
the most relevant for those documents so
for this what I qualify for OSAP your
goal is to be able to build a model that
read these and recognizes this is
probably the most important attitude
says to qualify or to be eligible you
must be a Canadian citizen from the
resident or a protected person and then
you your model has to understand that
well if you're new in Canada you're
probably not these three things so you
should say no you won't qualify so
that's that's the goal of this test
which is pretty difficult so ms marko
what is the stands for stands for
Microsoft machine reading comprehension
data set what's unique about it is their
real-world questions so you know that
these are real things that people are
asking and they actually want to know
about these are real-world documents so
it's not just these clean edited
documents like things that you could
find in new sources or even in Wikipedia
but these are like real the answers can
be from blogs they can be from you know
a lot of content out there some of it
actually could be our adversarial as
well and then some questions are
unanswerable so a lot of people ask
questions that don't have an answer
nobody's actually answered it and the
goal for your model is actually not just
to pick the best the most likely answer
but also to tell that you know what I
can't answer this so we think that's a
pretty important part of comprehension
and as some of the answers also need
some inference so the biggest chunk of
inch inference and their answers are
these yes/no answers or yes/no questions
these are some examples this is a really
nice summary from paper from MS RA
called s net and you can see that these
are what are called these are the
synthesis examples they pull that that
you know go beyond just you know picking
a stance so the first is you might need
to just refine this tippet so if the
question is you know what are different
types of skin ulcers you actually have
to remove these numbers and just say
look it's so I think this person says I
remove the numbers and say this is what
the answer is the other one is you want
to combine evidence with question words
so sometimes we react
we have the user or actually have the
crowdsource judge write a full sentence
so if someone says what is economic
impact of Japan Earthquake you have to
actually use some of the words from the
question in your answer the third type
of thing you'll see is multiple evidence
from one passage this is a pretty good
one which is what is the timespan of
Roman Empire and you know the answer is
27 BC before some Navy so you get this
band and this band in order to answer it
sometimes evidence is across multiple
passages so you know who the addressees
see in the underworld
there's one thing talking about Achilles
another one about alpha Noor and then
finally this is the inference example is
there an age limit for learning speech
now you just let's read all this and say
no right and this is sort of a
distribution of it so we've got most of
it is these exact matches which is kind
of expand answers then we also have this
refining the evidence tip is about 20%
combining question works by two percent
multiple evidence about three to four
percent the inference about four and a
half percent so our ultimate goal of why
we're building this data set is to
create an agent that you can actually
ask a question it would then just go
read the entire web or everything
written and then reason over it and then
summarize the answer which is what
motivated us to write these you know
human generated sentences near the end
so summary do you want to get this okay
why I guess you don't need to summarize
that much you just talked about it like
10 minutes ago
but yeah this isn't symbolic approaches
QA hasn't really worked that well now
we're trying these neural approach to QA
which is doing much better then we have
a set of ongoing research so we're very
excited all the data sets out there Emma
so Marcos are a contribution we are
working on how do we get these neural
models to do reasoning as well so some
of the nice things you get from symbolic
reasoning how do we get them how do we
get neural models to do that and then
finally how do we interpret and
understand these models that's also very
important
[Applause]
Niq questions for Iran and jal song
right now before we start with the last
presentation and again you can hold your
questions for the panel discussion okay
I just wanted to personally thank Jeff
Fung for a beautiful summarization of
the previous work that I had been
involved with MS - you did it
beautifully and we did hit a wall and it
compelled us to work on paraphrase
pretty much single mindedly for the next
10 years
so it's wonderful to see that that wall
is starting to be climbed now so let me
now introduce Isabel Augustin el coche
de algún Stein sorry so if the Bell is
now a tenure tag track professor
assistant professor in computer science
at the University of Copenhagen she's
just recently moved from the University
College in London her main research
interests are weekly supervised and low
resource learning with applications
including information extraction
automated fact-checking
and machine reading from scientific
articles and that's what she'll be
focusing on today she organizes a
variety of shared tasks on information
extraction and is also involved very
much in the organization of very
interesting workshops the first women in
NLP workshop at ACL workshops on deep
structured prediction of ICML and we'll
hear about her work on scientific
publications thank you thank you very
much for the nice introduction and also
oh I don't think this is on hello is it
on okay yeah I can't really hear myself
very loud well thank you for the
introduction and thank you for inviting
me in general okay so I'm going to talk
about fact-checking and machine reading
of scientific publications so far you've
mostly heard about question answering
tasks
so the idea of fact-checking is that we
have a statement for example
unemployment in the u.s. is 42 percent
and we want to know is this statement
true or false based on some background
evidence we can pose this either in
statement form in statement form in some
logical representation or we can also
pose it as a question asking what is the
stance of Hilary Clinton on immigration
and then it can be a multiple choice
question answer question answering task
the other task I'm interested in is
understanding scientific publications
where we have a very long document
papers and we want to know things about
what methods and tasks and datasets they
use you might want to ask questions
about them such as what models exist for
question exists for question answering
or we might have a statement want to
where verify such as method a I'll
perform this method B for task C now
give you a brief overview of what my
view on quest sorry and machine reading
is and how I think an ideal machine
reading scenario would look like so the
first thing we have are questions the
the next thing we have that most people
kind of ignore is evidence and in order
to answer questions we need to retrieve
evidence and the evidence can come from
articles it can come from social media
or it can come from knowledge bases then
based on their questions and the
evidence the machine reading model needs
to learn to represent questions and
evidence in order to make sense of the
information and later on return the
correct answer so the representations I
usually work with are neural
representations but as we've already
heard about earlier back in the days
symbolic representations were also
widely used
and there are people working on the
intersection of those things okay so in
terms of the representations people in a
natural language posting they usually
work with sequence representation
methods such as RN ends and variants
they're off but it's also common to use
cheaper methods where we just encode
words and then average recitations of
words or even just view phrases as one
token so a method for tasks could just
be one phrase and one one token so then
finally based on the query and the
retrieved evidence and there are
plantations
we return an answer and the answer can
either be an explanation but it's
methods based on ireland's are widely
used or it can just be a string like our
own ends so this is kind of my idealized
way of looking at machine reading and as
I already said people normally don't
really look at machine reading this way
they don't really integrate the
information retrieval step usually they
just look at one document that your
machine contention of one document for
example and moreover they usually look
at component tasks there are plenty of
people only looking at representation
learning of words for example and this
can be a good or a bad thing and we'll
discuss this some more later
so the way I've looked at fact-checking
is as a stance detection problem and the
machine reading probably wants to solve
here as you want to learn how to
sequences of words to sentences or
paragraphs relate to one another in the
fake news challenge set up we had a
headline of an article and then a
paragraph and wanted to know this
documents confirm or deny or is it
unrelated or some other some other
possible answers to the headline and
there are several problems with this so
one problem is that the interpretation
of course depends on the on the headline
so if we exchange the headline and the
answer will be different and it's a
problem a test time where we have lots
of unseen headlines and then also sorry
and the the benefit here is that
actually there's there's often an
overlap between the headline and
document so we can design some methods
which measure the overlap and then based
on that at least say if they're related
or unrelated another stance rejection
scenario I looked at is the semivowel
intersection scenario where we had
tweets and then we had very very short
targets such as legalization of abortion
or atheism pro-life and so on and those
targets in theory should be a user given
and then again we want to know how do
they relate to one another and as before
the interpretation depends on the target
and the target is not always mentioned
in this in the tweet which is a very big
problem so we if we see a fetus has
rights too we need to somehow learn that
fetus relates to abortion to atheism to
pro-life without without having seen
that necessarily so the approaches we
worked at here we're kind of domain
adaptation and week supervision
approaches in order to solve that
now briefly about scientific paper
understanding so one task we worked on
is a scientific paper summarization
where we have a long paper and we want
to summarize it in extractive way
meaning we could take a text marker and
just mark this as a document and lift us
out as as a summary and we've used as a
binary classification tasks meaning each
sentence could be a summary a sentence
or not and there are lot to be working
on abstracted summarization which is to
generate a summary usually they work on
but with shorter text so because we're
working with very very long documents
here we we did a fine encoding of the
sentence in question and then of course
encoding of the rest of the document and
this works very well in practice just
briefly how with how we design this
dataset so we use papers from science
directs where authors actually supply
summaries they have to enter highlight
statements set and these highlight
statements as we discovered they
actually copy from the main part of the
text sometimes directly and sometimes
very formulated it a bit and this is
what we can use as a gold standard
answer stand so that the scientific
publication summarization task is then
to recreate those highlight statements
so to sum up and kind of to lead over to
the discussion I want to say some of the
research challenges that we face in
machine reading and also natural
language processing more generally is
that often they're often we only have
the small data sets it's also because
there are lots of niche problems and
people design lots of new data sets and
those people including myself work on
weekly revision multi task learning sent
me to division in order to perform well
even on small data sets another factor
that might play into this is that those
neural machine
reading methods are very very costly
which means as a researcher with not so
many resources it takes a long time to
run those experiments so I think small
data sets are actually kind of
attractive for for researchers even
though it makes more sense to use bigger
data sets it was a very few data sets
which consider large or multiple
documents as evidence documents as we've
seen already for question answering
there's been a proliferation of data
sets some youth toy TAS who are not very
well designed so an example for toy
tasks is data sets which have very very
small vocabulary for very very smaller
number of distinct words that are used
and some data sets are very easy to gain
so you can just design some some easy
rules in order to get a very high
performance so state sets we don't
really want to create so I hope in the
discussion we can talk a bit more about
how to design good data set thank you so
does anybody have a question
specifically for Isabel before we move
to the panel discussion if not then I
would invite all panelists to come into
our corridor or hallway and so the way
that we would like to do this is to
simulate a hallway conversation
so we'll imagine that our speakers are
now gathering in the hallway and they're
going to talk about each other's
presentations and they're going to ask
each other some questions and if they
don't I will ask some questions and I
would invite you in the audience to join
the corridor a discussion you can sit or
stand
whichever thank you sitting as your I'll
say my our hallway conversation okay I
think I hear you are all miked up now so
let me just say like I
really enjoyed all of your presentations
I'm just curious like feeling speech the
speech dataset seemed to have been
around for 20 years people are still you
know reporting results on the same data
set the same test set that they did 20
years ago so which of these data sets is
going to be around 20 years from now
should it be around 20 years from now
and if not what would it look like what
do you think I I don't think you know
they say gonna last to me yes I don't
think so either
all right - yes oh my god okay su-25 yes
baby yeah I mean I think well there's a
question of whether it will or whether
it should okay I guess people still
might be reporting yeah yeah I know it
should not I don't think any two data
sets will actually last 20 years in my
opinion I mean also you can speech the
situation different in speech they
problem is severe where you find it but
now we are talking about managing
comprehension
the problem is self is arguable I what
exactly is mushroom reading
comprehension all the visitors who are
developing nowadays can be viewed as a
stepping stones to a let go right we
know it's it's a it's a it's a grand
envision like to have computer
understand and natural language how to
reach there yeah the tricky part is that
comprehension part like the
understanding and I think maybe in the
end it's going to take a lot of datasets
to know like do these models actually
have understanding you know just like
when I think about you know how we test
kids reading comprehension it's not just
one type of question we ask them
multiple questions and I think that's
what's going to be important here - yeah
I think one of the other things that we
also only discovering what our models
are really really bad at like Percy
seriously prepend or you know append
sentence to just an existing text and
all the sudden our model them perform
well anymore and those are the kinds of
things that we're still learning about
our tasks so then we might have some
more datasets just
on testing those kinds of problems in
future and then once we can solve that
we might need some more data sets
perform some more yeah some more
challenging I guess I guess my question
one question is you know we had a vision
of machine reading but what does it like
can we can can we come to a crisper
definition what does it mean is it just
the ability to answer questions or is
human comprehension more encompassing so
you mentioned about how we test children
for example my current focus has been on
question generation recently so one way
one pedagogical method for teaching a
student's understanding of a topic is
can they generate an interesting
question so I mean that's kind of the
flip of that so what is what is what do
we think of as a vision of machine
reading is there a crisp definition or
is it well I mean I don't think we have
a crisp definition for humans for
machine reading comprehension then even
now you can see the curriculum goes from
really simple no you know grammatical QA
right all the way to let's say the LSAT
test which is way more complicated you
read a whole sentence like you're a
couple rules and then you say like you
know does this or which would be
sentence as a fit here so I actually
think there's a lot of complexity in
reading comprehension which is why I'm
personally very excited about there you
know we also discussed the same problem
with the medulla team when they were
here wishing there are editors three
aspects of machine reading comprehension
versus the knowledge representation a
second is the reasoning the third one is
tricky it's the common sense reading
apart from pointing patreons data set
and there's our assumption that given
the crashing the answer must be a has
been in the next given text and this HEA
is a very strong assumption and people
are not doing that in real life when
they come up with answers sometimes I
is on so without even reading that
without you and really document Union
document well and something is spelled
that you were mentioning the focus on
multi document is important because we
clean on information from multiple
sources and we use those to confirm
I guess maybe doesn't M s Marco is that
multi is just a step ahead but yeah but
it is multi document it's Molly document
yeah I mean maybe I'll say something
about like what is the role that data
said right so so I think there's there's
you know we there's a basically a
testing role and the training role which
i think which is distinguished I think
because once you put on your machine
learning have those two your civic about
data sets and you divide into train test
but I think for each of those parts
there's probably different things that
you would want for example training
maybe you don't need clean data set may
be different supervision is a better way
to do it also from the training
perspective the role the data set is
actually to not necessarily be a driver
of developing new methods but it's a
resource just like you know worn as a
resource or I guess in some sense image
net views of resource because you get
information and now this is
generalizable to other settings so maybe
that's the way we should be thinking
about you know data sets for training
for example the common sense stuff maybe
we need to you know develop ways of kind
of capturing you know common sense in
the more targeted way in the general in
a in a way that can be used for a lot of
other tasks and then on the evaluation
side it seems like you know you want
actually many different types of
evaluation measures maybe question
generation maybe you know knowledge
based population maybe you know question
answering of various forms and I don't
think there's necessarily should be one
particular you know format for
evaluation because if we're interested
in anything general-purpose it should be
able to do
many things and I saw quite a recent
paper that basically is proposing a new
method and testing it on these various
tasks so maybe that is more allowing the
lines of what you were recommen but that
you have a single model for the that
captures the representation actually
back to the speech task make sure they
did they said a lot or which a lot
spottin here's it's a speech of the
combination tasks so way define it's not
the speech in the pending tasks yes
understanding is always tricky yeah so
what do you guys think about the
proliferation of data sets is this going
to I mean I see a proliferation of data
sets if I look at the tasks available at
semi vowel or at Connell you know we're
getting an almost every not every paper
but many papers introduce a new data set
do we want to talk about whether that's
good or bad or what we're learning from
this as a field it Isabel do you want to
tackle that one so I think it's both
good and bad so so I always like it when
papers that introduce me datasets
evaluate on an old established data set
that tackles a similar problem and then
introducing new data set and argues why
this new data set is needed and I think
yeah we will still get some more data
sets but especially on the machine
comprehension but I think at some point
that the current trend will die down
again maybe you know in one or two years
I'm not sure I think it's somewhat of a
trend really what do you think I think
there's just like a very large design
space of things like you know when
you're building read convention should
you have multiple choice should you have
free forms you have spans or should have
some sort of you know combination you
know where do you pull your articles
from should it be what's the role of
knowledge graphs should be most all
command paragraph
and I think we don't know which one of
these is you know these have various
trade-offs and I think it's actually
good that these things can be explored
in parallel by different you know
researchers and you know people can but
I think it's important for these
datasets to be kind of open and kind of
accessible in a way that people can you
know actually evaluate and maybe as a
community we should do a better job of
you know putting them in some sort of
interfaces on I know I think Facebook
has been doing a little bit of that with
some of some of these things but but I
think it's at least for this period
until we have some clarity on what is
the what is a good direction or several
good directions I think it's natural and
I think it's good that people are able
to you know create datasets on I mean it
does take money and some work but it's
it's feasible so I over all think it's a
good thing as well
so going back to what we're talking
about before you know if you really have
true comprehend comprehension you can
have multiple you can test it against
multiple ways like it's a multiple
choice or multiple tasks so I think
what's nice about having all these
datasets is you can actually see this my
model work well against all of these and
and maybe you could do some multitask
learning so the better you are across
all these datasets the more I think
we're moving in the right direction so I
think that part's good but of course
there's like a bad side which is there's
too many datasets were a little
uncoordinated you might be kind of you
know spreading ourselves ourselves thin
but I haven't seen that happen it seems
like there are network effects with
these datasets so once like a community
sort of in a bottoms-up way decides like
this is this is the one we want all want
to work on for a while the work on that
until it gets exhausted then it moves to
a different one so no it's good people
creating all sorts of different data
science to test different aspects of
intelligence right because in carrying
surface know what if I then I I don't
worry too much about
these states eyes are not consistent or
you need additional efforts recording it
or this group so I know sickness right
allows the day things are open to public
and it will pick it out automatically it
does put a burden on somebody who's
trying to publish for example a student
or you know it's like oh you know I
you've reported results on squad and Ms
Marco but you know you didn't try my
favorite internet right and I thought
I'd hit that
okay important today thing is that the
reviews also need to be able to minded
hahaha so once again a call to the
reviewers in the audience question so I
mean I guess maybe comparing kind of
squadron MS Marco one of the reasons we
focus on kinds of span is just so that
the intern annotator agreement could be
young I which was I think I think it was
a good you know it's obviously it you
know leaves a lot off the table but it
was I think probably a good pragmatic
decision yeah one of the challenges I
guess I'm curious if you have thoughts
on how to address is and when the answer
can be some arbitrary scenting how do
you evaluate yeah we do have problems
yeah I kinda we are using metric metrics
such as blue one Roger we know they're
not perfect and internally we also try
and different metrics we don't have two
conclusion it either agree with you I
think they're always a trade-off between
how charming you are how realistic the
task should be and how easy can be
evaluated yeah like we've definitely
spent since we since we launched the
first version we spent a lot of time on
building you know making the quality of
the next version better and we are
pretty happy with the progress so I
think when we will have another kind of
refresh of it soon which would be bigger
and hopefully higher quality but it's
you know it is it is complicated when
you have a human generated an service
then how many are reference answers to
how we try to create a multiple
reference yeah it's expensive and
time-consuming and so Isabel for your
scientific summarization you also have
oh you're using the single summary as
given by the author yes do you have
multiple references also no it's just
one of one set of highlights so and
that's the author's perspective it'll at
that moment in time exactly I think
that's that's going to be a challenge
going forward with you know that that
there are also multiple perspectives on
you know what counts as a summary yeah
that is actually the the biggest
challenge with so most of for these
generating answers we evaluate on these
metrics somewhere that's been really
well in translation like Rouge and and
blue but the problem is you can write a
semantically similar answer that's
correct but have very little overlap
right and that's one of the challenges
that we are facing actually so I think
along with data sets metrics is another
area that people should focus on
especially on summarization how do you
create a great metric to measure
summarization so one recent book is
about attendee tosca generation Qashqai
into a ranking task when just my way
into the evaluation I just give you one
good summary and three best summary to
see if your model can get French rated a
good one versus bad words
comedians often how people view our
knowledge based population as a random
tasks
yeah you only do it in in the evaluation
yeah I guess I mean you can start bring
humans into the loop so that's easier
but there are always I mean we've been
thinking about using humans me to
evaluate some part of it but you can
also train kind of evaluators that oh
yeah a shame that's a lot of discussion
on how to
generated and you know automatic metric
yeah i learning a model it's not human
data yeah but again there's a whole
continuum between having humans
evaluator single one and having yeah
yeah true yeah just something in the
middle that worked in our concern with
having a automatic evaluators like it
will have some bias right and and then
you know Weiser model learning the the
bias or learning the problem solving a
problem I mean I think you just need a
metric that's faithful enough to human
evaluations to serve as kind of a signal
to Hill Climb or evaluate and understand
it doesn't have to be ventured into
trouble with that in summarization
everybody in the end believed it even
though it was demonstrated to correlate
with human judgment it nobody ever
really believed it somehow blue has
stuck but ruch kind of is in disfavor
and never was quite sure why that was
yeah principal there rather the same it
actually could give you a real example
so with estimate which is the work by
Emma sorry which is so Arnett was you
know trying to find the span so asset is
let me try and synthesize an answer and
it actually got better root scores than
Arnett on ms Marco but then when you
actually read some of the sentences
there though just like you know they're
not fluid right so it's it's like it's
not just getting the answer right you
need to also be legible I guess there's
a I just want to make sure that people
know if you have a question please raise
your hand and one of the mics will come
to you if you want to join in this
discussion otherwise I have a whole
bunch of questions and we're going to
keep going but please join if you want
because one of my questions now is what
is going to be the role of explanation
that was kind of part of our discussions
when we put up the abstract for this
session and maybe hints hints of it have
come from the various talks that we
needed you know what is what is going to
be how is the computer even if it does
understand how is it going to
communicate
it's understanding how is it going to
explain why it gave a particular
answering is that part of our role and I
don't think right now we've done a good
job of evaluating that you know I think
well people sometimes people are not
happy with neural net models because
they view Network more black boxes you
know it generate answers without
explaining why you generally like that
but when we talk about modern
interpretation I think we need to make
sure they're clear what the
interpretation for what if for I think
there are two reasons once to develop
the system either it will provide the
explanation to the users of the model to
convince the user that you should trust
the model I think Trust is a very big
example we've been working on some some
prediction engine for sales marketing
right it's obvious you call this
customer today and without providing
explanations or readings and no sales
pressing on a kind of formal
recommendation right it's crucial all
right but it's still open research
problems I don't know
yeah question is then what are good
explanations yeah I think this is this
is really really hard and again we would
need some human-in-the-loop kind of
setup which is very costly so I think
maybe that's why not so many people are
working on it yeah I mean you can see
just a explanation as just one
additional auxiliary tasks where you
just generate an explanation in addition
to your other you know you are the main
task and yeah so that really you need
some unique you need some feedback
otherwise you can't really done any
explanation seems to be compelling yeah
yes
so maybe animation is yourself oh my
name is Ian at University of Washington
so I have a question about the modeling
choices so in the recent year
six-two sick model has been the way to
go for a number of different tasks like
motion reading but also question
answering and summarization anything you
name it like machine translation image
captioning just convert that into a sick
- sick model and it feels like
principled in the sense the intermediate
representation just comes from the data
and it's entering training which just
feels right
except there's something strange about
how for for example motion reading it
requires like I forgot the degree of the
scale of the data set but like for
example squad the data set is huge but
focusing on like 500 documents mostly
and humans never really have to solve
that many QA questions in order to
really understand a new document and we
know that if we given like random
Wikipedia document and probably the
end-to-end models will not be able to
really understand what it is if the
domain is different so then just a
clarification the treatment has
documents are different yeah it is
different but it's maybe a similar in
nature so if you cannot suddenly give a
novel for example and ask yes oh there's
something strange about the the setup
and also sentence complete summarization
requires like one point more than 1
million I think sentence pairs and it
achieves a state of the art but if we
try to summarize a new sentence out of
new domains and probably it's not going
to do as well and seems a little bit
weird to me that there's this thing
called the language models which
probably learned something about the
language but it's not necessarily being
used in some of these other task
settings and whereas the humans we just
learn language and then we are able to
do a lot of these operations without
having to
try to compress a million sentence pairs
for example so I'm wondering if the
panel might have some speculations about
these modeling choices where and whether
end-to-end models will be able to really
push the limit somehow if we can come up
with new architecture or my therapy
until a new approach that we should be
thinking about sorry for the long
question I'll leave it to you guys I
think it's a little bit kind of maybe
the proliferation of data sets supports
what the a Jim is asking about because
there are so many things but but I leave
what are the modeling choices that
you're making here really depends on
your goal yes like I have a very
specific task in mind and that's my goal
and I would definitely try enter
inlining if I got the train later but at
least the only way to get optimal
solution given the data and give the
task but if we are talking about the
general artificial intelligence and we
want to learn some representation which
is universal universally useful for all
sorts of tasks then then a reason work
on multi tasker learning might be a
better choice so you could figure out a
lot of the tasks then try to learn sort
of universal representation which can
encode a language in a way that is
support different tasks then weekly
imagine atom or tasks you can support
the more universal the representation
could be actually human tries to
understand a language more like a
multitasker than you and again it's
depend on your on your ID pinnacle yeah
I would say that the CGC kind of pair or
attention based paradigm I think is I
mean it's a tool it is certainly the
case that I think because of these you
know benchmarks people focus on these
tasks and there's kind of very
a lot of specialization but I think the
arm if you wanted I guess to do I think
in my mind there's still a long big gap
between kind of these reading conversion
datasets and kind of a model which is a
kind of a world model that you can you
know the agent has that you can use to
kind of reason at a very high level with
I think abstraction is still something
that's kind of missing I mean there's
basically paraphrase and kind of you
know oh this entity looks like this
entity and it's very still closed I
think it's um you know if you think
about kind of IR is a bottom layer okay
you just matching keywords now we're
matching kind of fudged up kind of
concepts but it's not clear what the at
least to me what the path to is to have
you know I guess you know truly abstract
concepts that allow you to think about
the world and not in terms of text
because I think you know a lot of our
understanding is not based on you know a
textual representation about something
much more abstract yeah one of the most
interesting parts of our question was
the way humans learned and the way
machines were very different machines
have to get tons and tons of this data
either lay Boulder or semi-supervised
while humans seem for some reason seemed
like we don't need that much data right
and an example of that that I ran into
like the sticks with me is one of my
friends has a two-year-old and when he
first saw a dog you know he's like you
know his dad said that's a dog and then
as soon as you saw that he would walk
around and every time we saw a dog like
that's a dog that's a dog right and I'm
like oh that's an example one-shot
learning you know from what example you
just like learn this concept of a dog
and that's something that humans can do
that I think is really fascinating and
even better is is your child learning
like you read a description of a cat and
then you're like that's a cat right I
think that's that's really unique and
this is why it's important for us to
work on these problems like once we you
know I think it's going to take us a
long
time to understand like what is the
difference between humans and machines
and how do we get them to do that but I
think you know working on these
comprehension problems will help us
really understand intelligence and get
us there I mean the other thing that
people have worked on quite a bit is
multimodal learning so the based on the
idea that humans learn not only from
text but also from speech from from
vision from what they see maybe even
from what they feel and I don't know
it's just a way for words really I'm not
sure yeah I mean it's really really
interesting but if we think about
training a model in this way and then
also training it to work for Las Navas
domains then at some point it really
becomes infeasible in practice so I just
yeah I guess my question would be even
if you took all the tasks and you train
one giant model do you get a kind of a
more abstract representation that is
closer to this thing that we've been
kind of in pursuit of or do you just get
kind of some sort of union or
intersection represent no one knows yeah
I mean this that's definitely one of our
our bends like where we're trying to see
like you're trying to build this one
multi task model with a lot of NLP
common tasks right and we're seeing you
know how does it do and one of the
interesting things that does come out of
it is it does get easier to learn the
next NLP task so I think that part's
interesting but there's a lot of money
one thing I'll point out just from
perspective of history is that I
strongly believe that the continuous
models are the way to go because that is
you shall know the work you know a word
by the company it keeps it's not that
cat kind of all of a sudden drops off
and from cats not cat you know there's
there's a sliding scale between what you
call one thing and then it's a tiger
attack screaming right it's very and we
always knew that and that's the
principle of a dictionary because a
dictionary of a SWAT definition of a
swallow will be it'll be a bird that
swoops and catches flies and the
definition of a penguin is a bird that
catches fish under water and swim
so you can see that all of our concepts
are in fact continuous and it just keeps
going you know water is itself a
continuous so I think the continuous
models are the thing that is most
exciting to me and then how you put that
together and do the inference over them
you know those are things that you guys
are struggling with but I think that the
continuous models will stay now to push
to push that further I guess how much
continuous how much water you do want
things to be because there's there's
Dylan I mean it seems like there's an
intuitive notion of entities on the
other hand entities are also not clear
like there's objects and there is a kind
of useful abstraction to have yeah but
object identity is also not clear so
pretty Dennis very temporal right who is
the president of France today one person
tomorrow the next person I'm
specifically picking a different country
you know those are very temple but we
have so many different ways of modifying
our concepts so even an entity I am here
in as a working person but you know I'm
soccer mom as well and I have real wear
many hats even the physical entity
whereas many hats I think that's kind of
interesting too modification is very
important part of our language and
acknowledging that in our models I think
is is very important
somehow language is so this great
because I don't think so
I think our aggression of what we have
in our mind is necessarily discrete but
I think yeah the expression that's what
is precious yes the concepts are more
fluid but for whatever reason evolution
is lighted up and our language itself is
a summary of what we have in our mind
and the complexity of what we're trying
to communicate so one last mission sorry
I'm going to pick from the side
thank you for this is Muslim from IIT
Delhi thank you for the very engaging
conversation I was thinking the
transition of machine reading as it has
happened with Allah maybe five or eight
years the the earlier generation of
question answering systems were very
knowledgebase centric and very
influenced centric so can you answer
questions using influence over knowledge
base this is my proof chain this is my
final answer and the current version of
question answering is very a sort of
surface form machine comprehension
centric knowledge bases have sort of
gone into oblivion incidence is sort of
not being explicit I was wondering if
it's what what is your opinion about
this particular change do you think it's
particularly good change do you think
knowledge bases may come back do you
think with David's influence going on
it's just going on nearly that we don't
quite see it I mean what do you think
about this specific transition system so
I think there's still there's still room
for knowledge-based and there are people
working on the intersection of knowledge
bases and Newell methods so for example
at a DCL where work previously lots of
people worked on the idea of injecting
not background knowledge from knowledge
bases into a newer model which is which
is really really interesting and it's a
way of seeing
yes transfer learning from and from a
knowledge base so I think that still has
a no is a good single study actually we
are working on those frontal where we
have this knowledge were of course a
territory myself only as I'm knowledge
yet not a good fit in knowledge work we
try to encode the supporting information
using neural network models and using
the approach I just explode right
remember if you remember that reason it
has a non term memory case you can
encode the entire knowledge graph in the
internal memory by trying to answer
questions and and try to generate the
answers from the knowledge graph and to
a question I think part of this is the
trend we were talking about earlier
linking it
like knowledge bases were the most
interesting knowledge representation at
the time now we have these continuous
representations because we saw the the
knowledge bases weren't working like as
Lucy said a lot of concepts are fluid
and continuous so now that we have this
new continuous representation of
knowledge like what can we do with it
and I think that's why we're looking at
more of these these text type systems so
it's I guess interesting the thing
that's kind of appealing about knowledge
bases is that they give you kind of
abstractions that allow you to do
aggregation much more easily than with
text but of course I've worked on
knowledge bases you recognize how
incomplete and how how it's always
fitting us square peg into a round hole
and we'll be I think interesting is to
embrace the the kind of the kind of I
don't know the holistic aspect of
knowledge bases but in a more kind of
modern neural way so I mean it has
always been kind of traditional paradigm
if you were using knowledge bases you
have to do X traction populate a
knowledge base and then you do QA but
what if you thought about the processes
okay I'm going to go over Wikipedia or
clue whether whatever you have access to
and build some sort of kind of memory
store that's not anchored on the
documents and now given that you have to
support all of question-answering maybe
that would be a kind of a forcing
function that would allow you to kind of
learn the kind of knowledge base like
things but more in a in a fluid way and
hopefully the QA would be enough
pressure that you didn't you know forget
too much keeping yeah and keeping in
mind that the establishing the trust in
the answer or the understanding that's
given is I think a very important part
in our human-computer interaction it's
to establish that trust how do you know
that from where do you know that
yeah I would certainly sorry go ahead
I was going to actually say something
about that earlier about the trust it
seems like there's several levels here
kind of one of them is you can think
about precision and one is recall right
so you know we trust search engines
because they give you know it and if it
gets answers you can get the provenance
you can look at the one page so on but
on the the recall aspect it seems like a
very hard problem how do I know that if
I this is the you know the full truth in
some sense and not something that hasn't
been hidden and as more kind of
complementary or contradictory
information gets chosen you can
basically give probably at select and it
specifically that's why I like the rumor
eval that as well as you know working on
and I think those will be very important
and of going forward so speaking of
search engines is also a person ization
problem so someone else's persons
someone else's truth might not be your
truth for another first query okay but
it is true that it is now past 12:30 and
you guys definitely thank you very much
and I think we need to have lunch all of
us thank you
[Applause]